I'm hearing strong rumors Stephen Jones
is going to go up in flames and that
Sergey Pavlich versus Jones is happening
in August I'm hearing strong rumors on
that and strong enough that I can tell
you that's at least being pursued I
don't know where they are in a green but
that's at least being pursued and if you
did have Partners in Australia you
promised them Izzy he said look I can't
deliver but I can bring you Jones and
tablets are we good they probably say
yeah we're good what I have to give Jon
Jones credit for I really do and that
pains me I gotta give him credit here
because people have said he was gonna
fight steepe and then he's going to
retire it's like well hold on people let
me remind you of one thing when you talk
about the mindset you talk like Jon
Jones doesn't have the courage let me
just remind you to be fair he thought he
was fighting Francis he agreed to fight
Stipe and he ended up in there with
surreal